right now Marvel Studios has been making
big changes to a lot of their upcoming
projects and to their strategy moving
forward with their movies and with their
Disney plus content and today we have a
great example of how this can be really
really good for the MCU what was
previously rumored to be a Disney plus
special presentation about Nova is now
reportedly going to be an entire Nova
movie which is fantastic I think Nova is
a character that deserves a film instead
of just a special presentation although
I think a lot of fans would have been
happy with the special presentation as
well but this means Marvel Studios is
taking a step back like they said they
were and looking at what is truly going
to work not only that but they did say
they are going to scale back on Disney
plus content so Nova going from a
special presentation to a full
featurelength film gives us even more
signs that that is truly what Marvel and
Disney are doing and not only that but
it looks like they are setting up
characters for the future of of the MCU
Beyond Avengers Secret Wars which is a
great thing because yes the X-Men are
going to be coming yes the Fantastic 4
are coming but we still want remnants of
the old universe that we know and love
to be left over in the new universe
especially since we've heard it's only
going to be a soft reboot after Avengers
Secret Wars not a fullon hard reboot
where everything is completely reset and
we start over from scratch that is
reportedly not what's going to happen
which is great I think but let's talk
about what a Nova movie could mean
including the return of Thanos to the
MCU and the setup for Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 4 but first if you're new
be sure to subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel news we also start our new
giveaway for the month of December if
you want a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items all you have to do is
subscribe to the channel leave a comment
on our videos we pick a random comment
at the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item we'll announce our
November winner tomorrow so be sure to
check out our video tomorrow so this new
report is coming from Daniel rpk and he
actually has two very recent reports one
about Nova as we've been talking about
but another about Daphne Kean returning
to reprise her role as x23 in Deadpool 3
now this is kind of expected but at the
same time a lot of fans are kind of
confused because Hugh Jackman said that
the events of Deadpool 3 are supposed to
happen before the events of Logan that
way Logan's death is not taken away they
don't want to erase everything that
happened in Logan The Death of Wolverine
the death of Professor X both actors
have said that that was it for them they
said their goodbyes there but of course
now the Multiverse is here in the MCU
and a lot of the actors who played those
original X-Men characters for the fox
Universe have expressed interest and
also kind of disappointment that they
never got to be a part of the connected
Universe they never got to be a part of
the MCU well we know that is changing
with Deadpool 3 and Secret Wars because
a lot of them are coming back and will
finally be able to be a part of that now
real quick as far as x23 goes we're
probably talking about some type of a
variant I don't assume this will be the
same one that we saw from Logan but if
it is we also have no idea of what point
in time she will be pulled out of like
if this is the Wolverine from Logan
clearly he's being pulled out of a point
in time that's from the past before he
died the same thing could go for x23
whatever Direction they choose to go
with this I don't think whatever they'll
do will undo Logan's death so if you're
worried about that I wouldn't worry too
much Hugh Jackman already said that's
basically not being touched but
according to Daniel RB UK we will see
x23 in Deadpool 3 and of course like
we've been talking about he stated a
project centered on Nova which was
originally going to be a limited series
is now being reworked as a feature film
so interestingly he states that it was
going to be a limited series we've heard
that Marvel Studios has been looking to
do more limited series recently instead
of fullon six episodes to 9 episode
series more condensed series like three
episodes maybe and it seems like Nova
could have been moved from a special
presentation to a limited series and now
to a fature film which I think is
fantastic especially because there's a
lot of story to tell about Nova and
Avengers Infinity War set this up years
ago and this is what could actually set
up the return of Thanos in the MCU
temporarily of course in Guardians of
the Galaxy volume 1 we were introduced
to xandar and the Nova cor the Guardians
ended up saving xandar working with the
novacore in which then the novacore then
pardoned them for all of their crimes
that they committed becoming allies with
them then in Avengers Infinity War Thor
told him that Thanos decimated xandar
and he took the Power Stone now if
you're not aware in the comics Richard
Ryder AKA Nova is a teenager on Earth
who suddenly finds himself imbued with
powers after the last xandarian left
Roman day chooses Richard Ryder chose
him to become the last novacore
Centurion giving him the powers of the
Nova Force we assume that the origin for
Nova is going to be pretty similar in
the MCU since Thanos decimated xandar
there's probably going to be one
surviving member left who will choose
Richard Ryder probably on Earth to
inherit the Nova Force if Marvel Studios
goes this route this will most likely
mean that we'll finally see Thanos
decimate xandar at least fingers crossed
we do if they are going to show us kind
of the origin story of how Richard Ryder
would get the Nova force it would have
to begin there at xandar where the whole
Nova cor is decimated they get
completely wiped out everybody is killed
and one remaining novacore member passes
on the Nova Force to Richard Ryder now
keep in mind we've actually already met
Roman day who in the comics gives the
Nova Force to Richard Ryder we've met
him in Guardians of the Galaxy volume 1
played by John C Riley perhaps just like
in the comics it is him who is the last
remaining member of the novacore who
chooses some person on Earth to pass
down his powers to obviously this person
in the MCU would be Richard Ryder why he
chooses Richard Ryder we are unsure at
this point in time of what the MCU is
going to do with the story but again if
they're going to show the true orig or
we should see Thanos and we should see
the scene we never got to see of Thanos
decimating xandar and at the same time
this should actually be a pretty decent
setup for Guardians of the Galaxy volume
4 Nova has a great history with the
Guardians of the Galaxy in Marvel Comics
and since the new Guardians team is well
just that knew with the current roster
right now although a lot of fans love it
they could use a very big lead since
they are missing a lot of the key
members that they had before Nova would
make a perfect addition to the new
Guardians of the Galaxy team and it
would make for even more excitement for
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 4 which I
think is desperately needed since now
James gun is gone and the team will no
longer have Star-Lord Drax mantis gamor
nebula I think Nova is actually very
much needed for this new Guardians of
the Galaxy team him along with rocket
King Groot the new Adam Warlock Kling
Cosmo and Fila would be a pretty epic
team if Nova kind of took over the
Star-Lord position because I think the
Guardians the new Guardians that is do
really still need a Star-Lord type
character and I think Nova would be the
perfect person to take over kind of that
leadership role for the Guardians even
though rocket technically is the leader
Nova can still come in and fill the void
that Star-Lord would have left and last
but not least Patrick Stewart has
recently commented on his possible
return to the MCU as Professor X in an
interview with e talk he says that it is
a possibility of course he cannot come
out and outright say yep I'm coming back
he's not allowed to do that legally but
I'll leave you with this final clip
don't forget to subscribe and like this
video and we'll catch you all in the
next video woof woof rumors that we may
see you in the Avengers Secret Wars do
you want to put that rumor to rest right
now um I I I cannot put it to rest
because it's not a fact either for or
against it it is a possibility Hugh
Jackman and I looked upon Logan as being
our
farewell uh given that I died in that
film although it's a Multiverse I've
been told I've actually died several
times already right he just keeps coming
back
folks how do I do it but so there's a
possibility and that's all we need
that's all we need that is enough for us
to get excited know that and uh you
could get lucky